this is back son it was the home of your
grandparents and their grandparents
before then but out there beyond the
edge of the world
why is the home of the Dragons and I
believe that your destiny to one day
find this head model congratulations the
final film I'm gonna ask you to she's
just sort of maybe one of you tell us
where we left off with the last film and
where this film picks up well in the
last film we left off with hiccup
becoming chief yes because stoic is gone
and volka coming to being Berk as you
know with with hiccup and and us having
a lot of new dragons that we rescued and
then when we pick up in in the third
movie Berk is just overrun with just
hundreds and hundreds maybe thousands
yeah so it starts out like with a bang
yeah yeah a lot of I know for you for
you since the first film I mean sort of
going into the hidden world it's a whole
new world to explore so what can fans
expect in terms of like visually house
it's gonna be different from anything
we've seen
well we've seen caves in the previous
movies and even a really elaborate
beautiful green house like cavern when
that was vulcan's layer where the
bewilder beasts lived in the second
movie so we knew we had to do something
different and part of the goal is to
take this movie where Cressida Cowell
books ultimately go which is the
explanation of where the Dragons went
why they are not here anymore
and if the Dragons were going to go away
we wanted to give them a place it was
really magical really amazing that you
you could dream to visit one day and so
the concept was to take bioluminescence
and to take the idea of coral which
might be grown in in midair and this
very sort of saturated salty wet
atmosphere yeah and to create an endless
tunnel
caverns and and that's sorry an endless
maze of caverns and tunnels that would
travel the globe
you know beneath the oceans beneath the
continents a world unto itself where the
dragons would originate from and go back
to Wow when I think of a hidden world
like I me Dee Utley go to like if I
could imagine a hidden world so for
either of you if you had a hidden world
what would it look like if you could
create it's a bunch of it's a bunch of
like Hobbes memorabilia and a bunch of
swords and Christmas lights I mean is
your word not mine yes it is my hidden
world yes my hidden world would just be
like lots of beds everywhere thank you
that's where I could just like roll from
one sleepy position to another position
yes cuz I'm gonna your mom and all I
dream about is how that works yeah and I
mean this has been almost 10 almost 10
years since the first one she's the
first one came out but yeah 12 years
yeah we started making the first so how
how have the characters or has the
experience changed or affected either if
you have you taken anything away from
from the characters if they infuse their
way into your own self it's it's
inevitable ya know I've never played any
character for as long as I played hiccup
and yeah and there's times where it's
it's hard for me to see where he starts
and I end it cetera etc and you know
like we said we started 12 years ago and
by you know sheer virtue of that passage
of time I'm older than I was when we
when we started and the biggest takeaway
for me is like what a blessing it is to
to play such a minor role in something
as special as this you know I feel like
I've gotten a tag-along on these movies
for ten years and it's it's been an
adventure yeah I feel
same way Jay and I are always talk about
how we we go see the films like we were
fans because we're in a booth you know
reading does a beautiful job of trying
to paint the picture of what's happening
but mostly it's in our imaginations and
we're not even together so we record
over the years of them when we sit down
to watch these stunning masterpieces
it's for the first time really and I
mean I'm I I'm so grateful to have been
on this journey and and it's been just
amazing to watch each film evolve and
and grow and still be a part of the same
journey but each film sort of be its own
standalone amazing adventure and and I
credit Dean with holding that that heart
of the movie that's never wavered do you
remember the very first line that you
ever said in your character or do you
remember the last line that you uttered
in what was that last moment like where
it was the last one you weren't going to
be in the character any more likely the
last line was some sort of bit of effort
or something because they're constantly
needing realizing that I haven't made
enough exertions and you have to be the
thing and so likely the last day which
is just like it was probably made of you
know getting stuff that we needed and we
didn't get out yet and so most likely my
last line was something like in fact it
was a line we recorded in Toronto
because we flew up to show the movie to
Jay and it was unfinished booked a movie
theater and then we snuck off to this
little room where they do radio podcasts
and I had a handheld recorder and so he
had to say the line look he'll figure it
out I just need more time
[Laughter]
first Astrid recording session was just
a series of like grunting and screaming
like Astrid didn't have lines so much in
the beginning it's just like she was
just someone who kind of went wrong and
I'm glad it's evolved since even before
Dean was on the project yeah yeah yeah
so I know Dean that you put even fused
some little you know tiny little details
into the film there's a flux capacitor I
think it was in the first one which
which I don't have to true or not I know
those are fan theories actually I'm
wondering where that would be on a wall
it was a drawing on a wall so maybe it
was Oh okay one of one of Jays
forward-thinking drawing if you put any
little Easter eggs in this film or if
there's any little details that fans
should look out for well one of the
Easter eggs that we put in is in the
hidden world drago's defeated bewilder
beast because we're trying to weave this
narrative that all dragons are
ultimately redeemable and good and in
the hands of bad people do bad things so
we had the B world abuse with his broken
tusks as part of the celebrating masses
that are heralding toothless's arrival
and we also wanted to make sure that
people didn't confuse toothless being
the last of his kind with the light fury
so we see other light Furies in the
hidden world as well as just to help the
audience along with that idea what's
with the Star Wars The Empire Strikes
Back Return of the Jedi pain it really
what that has to do is with the movie is
just for me that was the the trilogy
that cemented my love of movies when I
was a kid
particularly the way we went from a new
hope to an empire The Empire Strikes
Back
because it was everything I loved about
the first movie expanded upon and and so
exactly grow know he's growing up and
he's wearing this cool gear which I know
is the inspiration for hiccups gear
exactly exactly that lightsaber e-type
thing that hiccup had yes yes and so
yeah there's so many so many
inspirations that have found their way
into the how to train your dragon
Universe but overall the idea of a
trilogy telling a story in three acts
over three installments was was inspired
by that initial Star Wars trilogy and
you know you've talked about how both
the first two films ended and it was a
risky choice you've made at the sort of
certain ways you ended the film do you
think this is risky how many tissues
boxes of tissues do fans need to bring
with this is it ugly crying is it am I
gonna ugly cry or is it gonna be like a
good cry like a come on I
we cry you did all right for me to know
if it was like there was obviously
what's happening in the story but also
it was dawning on me that like this was
the end of like our era you know our
journey with the movie and so I feel
like my ugly cry a little
we didn't quite squeeze a tear out of
Jay because right as the climax hit the
the projection shut down in the movie
theater I cried right at the right
moment and then couldn't turn it off oh
wow and lastly why should people go see
this on the big screen why does this
demand to be seen in the movie theater
because this is why you go to the movies
this is a big escapist story you get
immersed in a completely different world
you will have your imagination hijacked
our 3d are flying is still the best in
the world and so it's one of those
experiences that like I'm the one to say
anything is lost at home but movies like
this or why we go to the cinemas and if
you've seen any of the other two films
and you have loved any or all of these
characters it's it's so rewarding to
watch them sort of grow up and also step
into new you know aspects of themselves
and of their life and it's like tying up
you know something with old friends it
you you really do feel like you get a
sense of who they've become based on
where they started we also have we've
been at this for 10 years so the
technology has evolved every year and
what we've managed to put on screen is
finally the fulfillment of the ambition
that we had from the beginning the scope
the scale the the detail I mean it's
amazing you see every grain of sand
every wisp of cloud and every reflection
on the water so to see it on a big
screen is quite overwhelming because it
it has such a visceral kinetic effect on
the audience and
it's great to be in a group of people
when they're feeling the the emotional
pivots as well so if you're going to cry
you might as well try with a group of
people in the first film you could only
see so many dragons in one shot yeah I
think we could put eight characters
human or dragon on screen and if you
tried to put a ninth and it would just
crash thousands yes yeah this the the
scene where where hiccup and America
sorry hiccup and Astrid are flying
through the fireworms I think we have
something like 14 thousand of them are
you sure at the same time versus seven
or eight
you